i have a question actually about market
share which is sort of what we're
getting at there has been a suggestion
that because of pricing and design apple
tends to appeal to kind of a smaller
elite rather than that sort of mass
customer base and so i guess once and
for all is it your goal to overtake the
pc in market share
i can tell you what our goal is
our goal is to make the best personal
computers in the world and make products
we are proud to sell and would recommend
to our family and friends
and
we want to do that at the lowest prices
we can but i have to tell you there's
some stuff in our industry that we
wouldn't be proud to ship that we
wouldn't be proud to recommend to our
family and friends
and we can't do it
we just can't ship junk
so there's there's a there are
thresholds that we can't cross because
of who we are
but
we want to make the best personal
computers in the industry
and we think there's a very significant
slice of the industry
that wants that too
and what you'll find is our products are
usually not premium priced
you go you go and price out our
competitors products
and you add the features that you have
to add to make them useful and you'll
find in some cases they are more
expensive than our products the
difference is we don't offer stripped
down lousy products
you know we just don't offer categories
of products like that but if you move
those aside
and compare us with our competitors
i think we compare pretty favorably
and a lot of people have been doing that
and saying that now for the last 18
months
if you want to see steve jobs explaining
his marketing philosophy check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there
marketing is about values
this is a very complicated world it's a
very noisy world
and
we're not going to get a chance